great uncle jaime it was great tell me
about my great uncle
uh so great uncle jaime was part of a
family folklore suggests that a
great uncle jaime was part of the all
gate mob when it became clear that the
government weren't going to block
mosley's march which a hundred thousand
people had signed a petition asking
uh asking him asking the home secretary
to do
a group of a group of jewish men
and women got together and collected
weaponry
and by weaponry it was whatever they
could get snooker queues and chair legs
things like that anything like every uh
every coffee shop every snooker hall was
visited anything that was wood that
could be turned into a weapon was
collected
jaime then helped also collect money in
order to
see if they could bribe ineffectually
the police to look the other way
and they got ready for what was 80 years
ago a great street battle
and do we know what happened to your
great uncle during the course of that
did he did he get arrested
did he get injured he managed to evade
arrest he did get hurt in one of the
fights but he also
managed it gave as good as he got so a
great uncle jaime did what needed to be
done
now what do you think the lessons are
for today i was talking there about uh
you know anti-semitic abuse
appearing to be on the rise but more
broadly you know the issue of
racism and and hate crime it hasn't gone
away from british society has it
no intolerance definitely hasn't gone
anywhere before i got elected i ran hope
not h
and we've seen politicians for decades
use vile
hate political rhetoric the bmp and now
ukip
we've you've just been talking about
donald trump in the states so
evil hateful rhetoric hasn't gone away
and it has genuine issues and impact on
communities it's had a real impact
since brexit we've got to be standing
firm i'm doing some work
on a cross-party basis to see how we can
encourage other colleagues to manage
their rhetoric in this period of
negotiation
but we've got to be really vigilant and
social media has made it easy for people
to
write down put on record whatever they
think without any
consideration of the long-term
consequences have you found a bit of
that yourself
i mentioned that what have you had
thrown
oh i think i don't look at my social
media feeds anymore there's no benefit
to that there's sheer volume over the
summer was
appalling and you saw i saw it i
experienced it myself from the volume of
abuse that you that is online and how
that then leads to death threats that
are tangible real death threats well
let's talk about uh you know trying to
sort it out i mean of course um
you're a member of a considerably strong
party itself and they had that recent
review into anti-semitism carried out by
baroness chakrabarty
do you think that was enough do you
think that the labour party your own
party now
is facing up to it i think jeremy corbyn
gave his strongest statement
condemning anti-semitism in his speech
at labour party conference and i welcome
that i still think we've got a very very
long way to go
we saw events even at labour party
conference of anti-semitic abuse
on stalls and um and around conference
and i think that if that's the case
inside
her majesty's opposition party we've
still got a long way to go
but i welcome the efforts that have been
done thus far and now we've got to
remember
and what about you know broadening it
out you touched on it there i touched on
it as well the issue of
hate crimes and uh we're going to see a
a report
coming up to fairly soon on whether they
actually
have increased since the the brexit vote
what's your understanding even from your
own constituents in my constituency
there's been a definite spike in hate
crime post brexit
over 100 increase in hate crime that's
been reported
i'm more concerned about those people
that don't feel empowered enough to
report it
so i've rush into every eu national in
my constituency to reassure them that i
will help them with the things that they
might need in the coming months
and that led to a number of them
contacting me about the abuse that they
were seeing on the street and how they
felt and no one had reported it to the
police so i think that we've got to be
really clear about
what is the official increase and also
how the culture is changing and what we
need to do to stand up to that at every
level
just let me take you back to cable
street there was so there's a historian
wrote a while back about the british
union of fascists that was the
organization led by oswald mosley were
actually quite pleased
about the the turnout because it was
waning at the time and that
it helped recruit members because i
thought oh you know this looks like
something we'd like to get involved in
you know the issue of confronting the
fascists why don't just let them you
know
walk down get away with it well i think
it's really clear we've got to always
uh have that fight i would argue we've
killed the bnp for example as a
political entity
but we haven't beat their ideology so
anti fascism always needs confronted
racism hate
needs confronted it's how you go about
it and let's remember that the battle of
cable street
occurred because government didn't
listen when communities ask for help
everyone
needs to learn lessons from what happens
at cable street but then we also need to
understand the concept of solidarity and
what was on that day working class
solidarity rick smith very good to see
you thank you very much indeed and
some wonderful memories there of uncle
johnny and the battle of cable street